6 41 good morning it is time to see what
is trending with las vegas now host
mercedes martinez joining us live this
morning from the mix 941 studio mercedes
good morning to you how you doing today
good morning so happy to see you guys
first up today and what's trending a
mega star boy band announced a new
residency
[Music]
that is bts and unfortunately they won't
have shows on the strip they actually
have a mini residency on tap in los
angeles at sofi stadium they will
perform november 27th and 28th as well
as december 1st and 2nd now the band
says if any tickets are left after the
pre-sale they will be available to the
public starting on october 9th
also what's trending skittles the lime
ones have been gone for eight years and
they're finally back starting next month
they're going to be mixed in with the
original and sour packs now skittles
replaced lime with green apple back in
2013 we don't know
yet what's going to happen to the green
apple john heather do you guys have a
favorite do you eat your skittles in a
certain flavor order john is a skittle
snob not a no no no no no no not a snob
like connoisseur i skittles mercedes are
my death like if i open tonight yeah if
i if i crack open a bag of skittles i'm
done
done the whole thing rip right through
the whole bag i can't just have one they
have to have the whole sleeve just like
all the way but you like the original
you don't like the sour or the berry or
anything fun yeah mercedes og skittles
for me
assistant do you go i see i have to eat
mine in a certain order i start with the
yellow then i go green then i go orange
then i go purple and then i end with the
red save the best for last i usually try
and eat them in threes that's my move
okay it helps me um
speaking of uh things so sometimes
skittles helps you chill out does it a
little candy just to kind of wind things
down doesn't it it winds me up we need
to find more ways to calm down don't we
more ways to woo saw perhaps yes
mercedes yeah well see you know in
movies and tv shows when you see a
person and they splash water on their
face it looks very dramatic but
apparently it actually works so mental
therapy health therapists say that this
triggers a host of soothing responses
throughout the body which quiets the
nervous system you can get the same
effects if you want to be even more
dramatic by diving into a pool or even
an ocean so maybe we combine the
skittles and the water and we splash our
faces wait so it's the same concept work
when the coaches get dunked with the
gatorade at the end of the game because
i'm not sure they're feeling very zen
i don't know yeah i think that's the
opposite effect right yeah i think it's
a little bit different they're all tuned
up in the game
i love that idea i think a little water
splash in the face to get you ready on
your morning to get you through the day
like you're part of your lunch break a
little water splash just kind of zen out
a little bit we need a dunk tank in here
anyone
if
everybody doesn't work well with our tv
makeup now that could be disastrous
running and melting bit of a problem
mercedes thanks a lot we'll see you on
uh we'll see on las vegas now later
today thank you ladies
thanks guys
i